ils convergent papier ou en tracteur
depuis jeudi des centaines de milliers
de paysans du pendjab en colère tentent
de prendre d'assaut la capitale et
compte bien y rester chacun dans notre
acteur est chargé avec des provisions
pour quatre mois
le blé a été semé et des agriculteurs du
pendjab et de l'haryana sont maintenant
tous libres tant que le gouvernement
n'aura pas annulé ces nouvelles lois
aucun d'entre nous n'y retournerons on
est venu ici pour faire en sorte que le
gouvernement retire ses lois notre
mouvement de protestation se déroule
depuis deux mois dans l'haryana et le
pendjab mais le gouvernement n'y prête
pas attention on a décidé de venir à
delhi pour faire pression sur le
gouvernement national afin qu'il retire
ses lois des lois adoptées fin septembre
par le gouvernement du premier ministre
narindra maudit pour les agriculteurs
fini de vendre leurs produits uniquement
sur les marchés régulés par l'état avec
des prix fixés ils ont dorénavant la
liberté de les vendre à un acheteur au
prix de leur choix mais le parti du
congrès le principal parti d'opposition
au pouvoir au pendjab à cusset réforme
de mettre les paysans à la merci des
gros acheteurs privés sans aucun pouvoir
de négociation on est des agriculteurs
comme la plupart des gens au pendjab
on pense que ça aurait un effet sur les
marchés agricoles publics et qu'on
devrait s'adresser aux marchés agricoles
privés qui nous paierait des tarifs
arbitraire pour nos produits
donc le prix minimum garanti par le
gouvernement ce qu'on obtient pour nos
produits agricoles ça va s'arrêter
des protestations qui ne touche pas que
le monde agricole
jeudi à l'appel des syndicats contre la
révision des lois sur le travail et la
libéralisation de l'agriculture
plus de 250 millions d'indiens ont
arrêté de travailler le temps d'une
journée soit la plus grande grève de
l'histoire